- You know, the things
you're talking about
are all kind of playing out--
- Technology is a son of a bitch.
Technology doesn't care
that you've been unbelievable
at your craft for 30 years.
Technology didn't care that
my dad's contemporaries
that came over from Russia
in 1978, moved to LA,
made two bucks an hour being a cab driver,
worked 20 hours a day,
saved every dollar for 13 years,
had paid their dues,
didn't see their family,
saved all their money,
bought a couple of black cars,
actually built a business,
saved all their money, worked
every day for 30 years,
finally getting to the moment
where eating all that shit
might pay off just a little bit,
and then Uber came along and
put them out of business.
Technology didn't care
that your grandfather came
from Europe, worked 80 hours
a day for his whole life,
built a small little book store,
your dad came along, your mom came along,
made it bigger, now it was your turn,
and it's a real great place,
and you're gonna take it,
and Amazon came along and
put you out of business.
Technology doesn't care.
I don't know what to tell you.
This is called capitalism,
this is the way it works.
And nobody's gonna cry for you,
and nobody's gonna cry for anybody.
That's the point.
And so of course that's happening.
This always happens.